welcome to CBS this morning everybody
okay at home because we are coming to
you from our homes to yours out of an
abundance of caution you know of course
we will continue to bring you the news
throughout the coronavirus crisis no
matter what and that of course is where
we begin because we have a lot of
developing news overnight including to
cruise ships off the coast of Florida
carrying hundreds of sick passengers
we'll get into that in just a moment but
first some very sobering numbers for you
more than 1,000 people died from the
virus yesterday in the u.s. in one day
bringing the total above 50-100 people
more than two hundred and sixteen
thousand cases are now being reported
yeah and surveying all of that Vice
President Mike Pence says we're on pace
to match hard-hit Italy and a growing
number of Americans seem to appreciate
that a CBS News poll out this morning
shows about half of Americans fifty-one
percent of us believe the outbreak will
get worse in the next month only 28%
think it will get better
David Beck know is in New York City
which has the largest number of victims
by far David good morning you're near
that remarkable field hospital in
Central Park an otherwise desolate
Central Park and the city apparently has
new guidance for emergency responders
what can you tell us they do Tony good
morning because of our proximity to the
tents where kovat patients are being
treated I'm wearing a mask and so is our
crew this is just as a precaution there
are new rules because paramedics who are
responding to the scene where someone is
in cardiac arrest are at risk but
there's a concern that patients in
cardiac arrest may have coronavirus but
just may not have been diagnosed and
since you can't diagnose on the scene
EMS workers in New York City have been
given a directive if you arrive at the
scene and a patient does not have a
heartbeat if you can't generate a
heartbeat with CPR and restart the heart
somehow someway do not transport that
patient to a local hospital for your own
safety and for the safety of the
hospital staff in the span of 72 hours
here in New York State the number of
coronavirus deaths more than doubled the
governor closed the playgrounds
who else has to die for you to
understand you have a responsibility in
this listen to how a nurse in Brooklyn
describes her ICU
/ someone passes away alright get the
room clean next person and immediately I
mean there's patients sitting in the ER
on ventilators waiting to come up so
there's really just no break she gets
one protective mask and she has to use
it all week we're also learning the
national stockpile of personal
protective equipment is nearly empty
difficult days are ahead for our nation
we're going to have a couple of weeks
starting pretty much now but especially
a few days from now that are going to be
horrific
currently New York City has fewer than
400 ICU beds available out of a total of
more than 2,500 our cameras captured the
first patient arriving at this Central
Park field hospital with 68 beds it's
funded by the Charity Samaritan's Purse
doctor did you bring your own staff yes
we did these are doctors and
professionals that are coming in from
the outside to come here and to provide
additional care additional services to
the people in nearby Connecticut the
governor announced what he called a
tragic milestone probably the youngest
person ever to die of kovat has died
here in Connecticut that baby was a less
than seven weeks old another five states
Nevada Florida Pennsylvania Mississippi
and Georgia all issued stay at home
orders that brings the total to 37
nationwide in New Jersey a 33 year old
firefighter died is your own a great
father person husband son Israel
tolentino leaves behind a wife and two
young children
back here in New York City at Central
Park it is surreal to see this feel
Hospital set up in the park and some
people biking as they do everyday in the
park to exercise there are 68 beds
there's only about a half dozen patients
who are here right now but Samaritans
percent its own staff as you just heard
in the story and Anthony they're doing
all of this free of charge here in New
York City and they have another field
hospital set up on the front lines in
Italy
yeah it sure is surreal David thank you
very much